alright let's take some questions from
the audience first question is from Jen
who says do you guys believe in the
butterfly effect chaos theory or karma
okay so let's address these one by one
if by karma you mean the sort of idea
that if you act in a way that is more
ethical you are going to sort of cause
better things to happen to you and that
if you act in ways that are unethical
you are sort of bringing on some kind of
future bad luck or negative
repercussions I generally don't believe
that pat in the literal sense although I
do believe that if you are someone who
tries to act ethically and help others
and and be moral that by virtue of that
you will probably have better
relationships and end up with more
opportunities and in more positions for
things to happen to you but that's not
really karma in the cosmic sense I don't
think no karma seems to be more of a
supernatural type of phenomenon I think
that people who don't identify as
religious but say that their spiritual
may be more likely to believe in this
kind of thing but for the most part I
just think it's coincidence I mean
coincidence happens all the time it's
all around us and I think sometimes
there's a more simple explanation for
these things that go on rather than
something supernatural like karma or the
butterfly effect okay so that's karma
now the butterfly effect there's debate
over whether it's supernatural or not
because the butterfly effect or
sometimes known as sort of chaos theory
is the idea that an action as small as a
butterfly flapping its wings in the
Amazon in Brazil for example causes a
sequence of events of growing and
growing sort of chain-linked magnitude
such that it could cause a hurricane on
the other side of the world okay and
there's a sort of scientific approach to
that which which which could seek to
answer the question generally speaking I
completely agree
that actions even small actions can have
consequences and some of those
consequences are sort of sequential in
the sense of a chain reaction that is
caused however many people who take two
they take this to the extreme in the
sort of butterfly example where a single
butterfly flapping its wings in the
Amazon creates a chain reaction of
events that builds into causing a
hurricane that otherwise would not have
happened on the other side of the world
it ignores sort of two aspects of
reality one is the cumulative effect of
events that take place on the planet so
if indeed the butterfly flapping its
wings had a role to play in a hurricane
that ultimately happened on the other
side of the world it could not really
have been that butterfly alone that
would have caused that but we might be
able to make a scientific case that it
was part of a cumulative series of
events that led to the hurricane
happening but there's another aspect
that's often ignored which is that
there's an underlying dampening ability
of our planet and the world that can
balance against any individual event so
as an example you could say okay i
rear-ended someone which caused that
person to be 10 minutes late getting to
work while we exchange insurance
information and because they were 10
minutes late they didn't interrupt a
funeral motorcade as a result of the
funeral motorcade not being interrupted
an attendee of the funeral was able to
more quickly get back to their office
and have a business phone call they
thought they weren't going to be able to
make and the decisions made on that
business phone call had such wide
reaching political implications that two
years later a war did not happen as a
result and thus me rear-ending someone
caused a war not to happen it sounds
very cool and interesting and sort of
metaphysically compelling the problem
though is that there is this dan
bending effect of going back to
equilibrium and at some point in that
hypothetical sequence that I lined up
the the sequential and growing impact of
the rear ending would be balanced out
because there was maybe 10 a buffer of
10 minutes already built in so that one
person getting delayed by 10 minutes
didn't end up having that impact or
something like that I don't know if I'm
sort of being cleared Pat with the idea
but when people talk about these these
butterfly effect hypotheses they ignore
the natural dampening effect of the real
world I mean I think this is certainly
true on a macro scale so to bring time
travel into this if we were to go back
in time and try to stop the
assassination of John F Kennedy there
would be so many world events that
happened thereafter that would
completely change the course of history
so if we're willing to accept that it
happens on a scale that big can we make
the same argument if we scale it down to
something as seemingly insignificant as
a butterfly flapping its wings I don't
know that we can I think it's kind of a
jump yeah although you know the the go
back in time one also gets into what's
called the grandmother paradox which is
if someone goes back and murders their
grandmother before she gave birth to
their mother could they have actually
gone back in time and done it because
they never would have been born because
they would have prevented their mother
from being born that's a whole other
thing that that is very interesting but
it's sort of a different interesting but
different question as well so big
picture conceptually I believe that
actions have consequences do I believe
in the butterfly effect as sort of
caricatured not really